free free free free will a candidate win
the White House by offering us the most
free stuff select up to $500 a month
never before have so many promise to
spend so much we need to go tenfold we
took care of the military like it's
never been taken care of before we have
got to pass a medicare for all
single-payer system how can you even
keep track of their proposed spending
400 million dollars in new science and
technology no one I know has even tried
to track their promises so we did here's
the tally we added up each candidates
proposed spending we limit our count to
the top five and the election bidding we
break it down issue by issue starting
with education triple the amount of
money we spend for title one schools Joe
Biden is off to a fast start the
universal pre-k free Community College
plus he doubled the number of
psychologists counselors and social
workers in schools 78 billion dollars
total but that's much less than what
Kamala Harris would spend giving the
American family all that they need
Harris would also make Community College
free but she dad on four-year public
College and increased government's
investment in child care dramatically
and give the average public school
teacher a $13,000 raise her total more
than doubles Biden's free college for
low and middle income students Meir
Buddha Theodore airily says what his
plans would cost but he at least
proposes less than Harris got to be able
to refinance your student debt he also
wants the feds to give teachers more
money assuming his plans like Harris's
that's a total of 87 billion we can make
it work for everyone Elizabeth Warren
would spend much more you'll be
debt-free some students will be that is
but you'll be deeper in debt if Warren
gets her way she would forgive most
existing student debt make public
colleges tuition free and she wants a
universal child
era Early Learning Act she's in first
place so far eliminate student debt but
Bernie Sanders would spend even more
he'd forgive all student debt we must
make public colleges and universities
tuition-free or up to 220 billion per
year but Sanders also wants universal
daycare and pre-kindergarten so Sanders
wins in education spending as the only
self-described socialist in the race I
assumed he'd win most categories but I
was wrong he's got plenty of competition
let's look at health care you cannot let
people who are sick no matter where they
come from no matter what their status go
uncovered Joe Biden would spend forty
nine billion to have the government
provide a public option like Medicare
Buddha Ridge has the same plan I would
call it Medicare for all who want it all
the Democrats also want to give Medicare
to people who came here illegally we
have got to pass a medicare for all
single-payer system Murray's plan would
cost even more on the our plan people go
to any doctor they want any hospital
they want Sanders says it would cost 30
to 40 trillion over the next ten years
three trillion per year i'm with bernie
on medicare for all medicare for all so
these three lead in health care spending
but something isn't clear who here would
abolish their private health insurance
in favor of a government-run plan the
three biggest spenders also support
banning private insurance unless they
don't Harris co-sponsored Sanders bill
which bans it but then in the view she
said she would not ban private insurance
and private insurance also because
that's what I had coupla mental private
yes then in the debate she raised her
hand to say she would after the debate
she again said she would not
I support the green New Deal and how
much will they spend on climate change I
support a green new deal all the
candidates except Biden say they support
a OCS green new deal so they can pretend
to be doing something about climate
change
Republicans say a green new deal would
cost 93 trillion but will go with the
lowest estimate we could find an
economist who likes the idea claims
it'll cost five hundred billion dollars
a year new science and technology Biden
would spend less but still a lot I would
immediately insist that we in fact bill
five hundred thousand recharging
stations some candidates would spend
almost as much increasing welfare
benefits for every family that is making
less than a hundred thousand dollars a
year they will receive a tax credit that
they can collect up to five hundred
dollars a month in addition to a tax
credit Harris also would have the
government pay your rent if it's more
than 30 percent of your income and she'd
increase food stamps for kids Warren
would do that too and make an historic
investment in housing booty ditch wants
affordable housing but gave those
specifics
I'll assume his plans like Warren's
senator Sanders wants to increase food
stamps expand Social Security benefits
and guarantee everyone a government job
so far Joe Biden has not proposed new
welfare spending so senator Harris wins
this round easily working families need
support and need to be lifted up I've
been counting up the Democrats plans but
the incumbent has have been very
responsible either a 21 billion dollar
increase in defense spending since Trump
became president spending rose about 500
billion Trump did send Congress budgets
that included cuts but Congress sent
increases back and Trump signed them and
drunk would spend even more 200 billion
for infrastructure 8 billion for wall
construction and more NASA funding how
can we afford this America is already 22
trillion dollars in debt $150,000 for
every taxpayer but at least Trump
proposes less
than the Democrats do finally we added a
grab-bag category because three of our
candidates have even more proposals
Harris wants to give a hundred billion
dollars to redlined communities Budaj
wants two billion to expand national
service but warren has the most plan
she'd require the government to buy
american-made product they have to be
manufactured right here in the United
States of America she'd also expand the
destructive export-import bank give debt
relief to Puerto Rico spend more on the
opioid problem and give two billion
dollars a year to apprenticeship
programs in total we counted 50 spending
proposals we try to include all of them
and figure out the costs but please in
the comments section below tell us what
we got wrong until then President Trump
has the lowest spending proposals
Biden's not that much worse booty ditch
would double Biden spending increases
and Elizabeth warden would spend five
times more Sanders is even worse but
even the socialist was edged out by
Kamala Harris I guess that means she's
the winner of free stuff 2020
no matter who wins since all the
candidates want to spend more new
taxpayers are the loser